so I think one of the big picture
challenges we have in this culture is we
often Define our values by a series of
things we don't do right I don't smoke I
don't lie I don't have sex before
married I don't do these things instead
of my values are based in here's who I
am here's who I'm becoming here's who I
want to be when you do lie your identity
stretches right your values stretch
that's what repentance is for that's
what saying I'm sorry is for that's what
confession is for but if your values are
based in a series of things I don't
don't do this thing and that's my value
I don't have sex before marriage and
then you do you're
done you're done you have nowhere you
have nowhere to come back from